why are we even having this conversation
some might say Dr Jane surely it should
already have been banned
well you wouldn't think so wouldn't you
you would think that as we're in the
sixth great Extinction as most of the
animals being given licenses for to hunt
and kill are endangered at least many
many of them are and
we now know that animals are sentient
beings they can they can solve problems
they can feel fear and pain just like us
and so the fact that we're allowing
people to go out and shoot them for fun
for sport is is something that shouldn't
be happening in this day and age
according to me
uh Dr Adam
um six separate African countries have
got a different View
yeah so there's a big Kickback against
this bull from uh governments of some
African countries and I mean we've got
to just state that those African
countries are in a minority in Africa
there's only a dozen or so African
countries that allow trophy hunting
those countries they have a vested
interest in trophy hunting a vested
interest for the government and for
those that benefit from trophy hunting
which is a minority few it doesn't
represent the views of Africans and
certainly from Africans in those
countries
um and Dr Jane they say the argument
goes uh that they need this money for
conservation and also to keep poachers
at Bay what would you say in response to
that
well first of all
um the money most of the money does not
go to uh to conservation it goes it
varies other directions
and you know talking to some of the
Rangers who spent and give their lives
trying to protect animals they are
completely horrified that well they are
protecting them people come along with
money from the white world and and can
kill them for fun and they don't
understand it more and more ordinary
Africans simply don't understand it and
I don't see how can stop
poaching
can you doctor in the studio no I mean
hunting does not stop poaching it
certainly doesn't go to communities I
mean you can run the numbers we've
worked out that the the money from
trophy hunting if it does get to the
communities amounts to 10 pence per
person per year that's on average the
British Trophy Hunters contribution to
to Africa is one penny for every 10 000
people
um the fact that that doesn't even get
through the communities uh you know is
is another story but basically trophy
hunting is this horrible horrible
practice
um with this narrative that it's
benefiting wildlife and its benefiting
people it doesn't it does quite the
opposite I mean we even have a situation
in Tanzania where 70 000 Maasai are
getting evicted to make way for a
reserve for trophy hunting now how does
that benefit communities
Dr Jen the other argument is that the
meat so it's just the head and the Pelt
that can be imported the meat is given
to local communities uh to feed them
well I mean a lot of the meat the local
communities they don't want to eat lions
or leopards it's not part of their diet
so it's just you know the odd elephant
and giraffe
but uh
I don't know I come back again and again
and again to the fact that there's no
proof in fact there's proof to the
opposite that this hunting is not doing
anything to conserve wildlife I haven't
made a study of it but uh Eduardo
Gonzalez spent years and years he wrote
three books about the subject and it's
just a fallacy that the community's
really benefit and the conservation
really benefits
and that you know there's one other
thing that I think is important to
mention and that is we we're just we're
still actually in the throes of
suffering from the pandemic the recent
pandemic that came from a stressed
animal being bought in a market and from
that stressed animal a virus jumped from
the animal to the person and actually
bonded with the cell in her body and
that led to the pandemic well these
Hunters you know they're pictured
sitting with the head of a wild animal
on their lap as they grin and gloat
having shot them from very close to a
car with no danger to themselves at all
and it's quite possible that a virus can
jump over from that stressed animal as
it was dying